these are the 14 strongest characters in
one piece whose true powers are still
unexplained starting with Monkey D
Dragon this mysterious man is the absent
father of Luffy and the leader of the
Revolutionary Army his stated goal is to
take down the corrupt World Nobles who
rule the entire world and while we've
never seen him fight whenever he shows
up strange things always happen for
instance when he appeared in loketown in
chapter 100 Luffy was saved by a freak
lightning storm that apparently arrived
out of nowhere or in the Goa Kingdom's
strong winds saved citizens from a
raging fire when Dragon arrived on the
islands and these examples have led many
to speculate that dragon has a devil
fruit or an ancient weapon that can
control the weather what a power to have
in this world that is completely covered
with water we also know that Luffy gets
his unbreakable will and his haki from
dragon as well and on top of that he's
also the most wanted man in the world
and judging by the rest of his family
Dragon should be one of the most
powerful characters in the story however
the the same time there's also some
evidence that Dragon may not be as
strong as many people think he is for
example Blackbeard was able to destroy
the base of the Revolutionary Army and
while dragon and the revolutionaries
easily survived it makes me wonder how
strong Dragon actually is but while we
can possibly question Dragon strength
one undeniable Powerhouse in Luffy's
family is his grandfather Monkey D guard
as the hero of the Marines GARP is a
famous retired vice admiral who was the
Rival and friend of former pirate king
Goldie Roger he's respected by literally
every single Marine in existence and was
even offered the position of Admiral
many many times though he always turned
it down he's even capable of defeating
yonko level characters like we see in
the special chapter strong worlds in
this special chapter he and former Fleet
Admiral sengoku takedown Shiki who was
Roger's main pirate rival and a member
of the Rocks crew but what have we
actually seen from Garb so far well
we've never really seen him fight all
out we do know that he has ridiculous
physical strength he throws cannonballs
like bullets brawls with his fists and
has top tier hockey and while he did not
participate during the ward marineford
GARP certainly felt capable of killing a
kainu after his bloodthirsty Admiral
punched a hole through ACE but is he
really one of the strongest characters
alive well in the past we know that he
rivaled people like Whitebeard and even
teamed up with Roger to take down Rock's
diesel back probably the most powerful
pirate in history but if he's really on
that type of level do we really believe
that he is just throwing fists with all
these top tier Fighters I mean every
other Elite fighter in the series uses
some sort of weapon or ability a sword a
gun or a devil fruit but we haven't seen
Garb use any of these surely he won't
just Chuck cannonballs at enemies like
Roger or Blackbeard so is he actually
hiding a secret ability or is he just
the greatest hockey master in all of One
Piece and what if I told you that GARP
was probably not even the strongest
Marine out there one character whose
powers are a complete mystery is the
world government
commander-in-chief Kong but just look at
this absolute chat of a man who would
want to stay step up to this dude in a
fight even though we don't know his
individual fighting strength we do know
that he controls the Marines and Cipher
poles and since Marines are usually
promoted based on fighting ability Kong
must have had incredible Powers since he
was the fleet Admiral before sengoku and
Akainu and there's a likely explanation
for why Oda is keeping his abilities a
mystery you see he could very easily be
one of the final opponents the straw
hats face on their journey and we will
learn more about his powers in the final
battles ahead and speaking of the straw
hats there have always been many
questions about Zorro and sanji's true
abilities as well like does Zorro's
unrelenting drive to be the strongest
swordsman in the world mean he will
unlock Congress haki and how exactly can
Sanji light his legs on fire well during
the wano arc we finally got answers to
both of these questions after Zorro Cuts
kaido deep enough to leave a scar the
yonko himself tells us that Zorro just
attacked using conquerors hockey no
other confirmation need it and as for
Sanji it turns out that he has
genetically modified genes these genes
are from an almost extinct race of Sky
people that have the ability to create
fire at will and now that we finally
fully know how these unique abilities
work it hopefully won't be long until
Zoro and Sanji reach the level of the
rest of the characters on this list and
one of these characters that we also
just learned a whole lot more about is
Shanks what we've long known is that as
a child chinx was a cabin boy on Roger's
crew and before losing his arm he could
duel evenly with the strongest swordsman
in the world he even stopped the entire
War at marineford without even fighting
and in the most insane Conquest hockey
Flex in the entire story so far he made
a literal Admiral runaway crying from
miles away but it gets even more insane
thanks to the information in the booklet
released with one Piece Film rats
because in it we learned that Shanks can
coat his sword in a fiery Aura similar
to Luffy's red hockey also shanks's
nickname in battle is the killer of
observation haki meaning that he can
even stop other strong characters like
Luffy from using their future side
ability using his own hockey mind
blowing truly Shanks is the definition
of a badass character and he is going to
show Luffy that there is still much much
more to learn about hockey but despite
all of this new information there's
still so much about his powers and goals
that we don't know what we know for sure
is that he didn't have a devil fruit at
the start of the series but it is
possible that he ate one between chapter
one and becoming a yonko besides his
fighting skills he has the cloud to
drink booze with Whitebeard the
influence to stop kaido from coming to
Marine Fort and the Swagger to walk into
marijua to chat with the actual gorosei
also it is possible that he could be a
world Noble or even something more crazy
like the son of Roxy's back whatever the
truth is we should find out soon as he
is finally going to take an active role
in the search for the one piece now and
very similar to shang's another pirate
searching for the legendary treasure is
Blackbeard this man is also a yonko one
of the most dangerous pirates in the
seas and is Luffy's main rival to
becoming pirate king but the most
mysterious thing about him are his devil
fruit Powers that's right I said Powers
by some unexplained process Blackbeard
can use both the darkness fruits a power
that is a whole Mystery by itself and
the Tremor fruit which is said to have
the ability to destroy the entire world
so what do we know about this hidden
ability that allows Blackbeard to have
multiple devil fruits at once well some
of the theories I've covered in other
videos range from the original devil
fruit being the three-headed dog
Cerberus or a mythical octopus him
having a Godlike through just like Luffy
or even Blackbeard being triplets that
are stuck in the same body each of these
theories tries to explain how it was
able to to eat a second devil fruit and
many wonder if he will even eat a third
one before he finally fights Luffy plus
we still don't know if Blackbeard also
has conquerors hockey but one thing we
do know for sure is that he has horrible
taste in pies and drinks at least
according to Luffy but perhaps
Blackbeard's most important secret is
his connection to the Legendary Pirate
rocks these are back as well Blackbeard
could be roxt's son just like Shanks his
clone worm even somehow have rocks
living inside of his body hold on what
one of the strongest Pirates ever living
inside of another pirate that's right in
one piece anything is possible Roxy's
back is surrounded with so much mystery
that we're dying to find out what
happened to him and more importantly how
he became so powerful what we do know is
that rocks was an Infamous pirate 40
years ago and that his goal was to
become king of the world to do that he
ruled over the most insane pirate crew
ever and was only stopped when GARP and
Roger teamed up during the incident on
God Valley however the island where this
famous battle occurred was erased from
history and we've never had confirmation
of Roxas death or his power but if it
took the Marines GARP and Roger to
defeat rocks then he must have been a
monstrous fighter many theories point to
him being the former user of
Blackbeard's Darkness fruit or another
overpowered devil fruit users such as
the lightning fruits whatever it was if
his goal was to conquer the world then
he surely would have possessed one of
the strongest fruits in history and
incredibly strong will and hockey on top
of it another participant in the famous
God Valley battle was the dark King
Rayleigh Rayleigh was Roger's former
Vice Captain and is said to be nearly as
strong as the former pirate king himself
he is one of the most powerful Swordsmen
in the series he can easily go head to
head with a marine Admiral and he's a
master of all forms of hockey we also
know that Rayleigh doesn't have a devil
fruit as he's been shown on swimming
multiple times which makes his powers
even more impressive and so you might be
wondering why he is in this video well
he's one of the few living people who
have been too love tale and it makes me
wonder if he's hiding some other unknown
ability that we have yet to see in the
series and of course you can talk about
Rayleigh without discussing Roger the
former pirate king and the man who
kicked off the great pirate era Roger is
undoubtedly one of the strongest one
piece characters ever we do know that he
also was a master swordsman who wielded
one of only 12 existing Supreme great
swords he was definitely not a devil
fruit user but there have been many
other strange occurrences when we see
him in battle for example in his fight
against cheeky a sudden storm saves the
Roger pirates from certain death sound
familiar and just like Luffy Rogers one
of the very few characters to have the
voice of all things a power that is
still completely unexplained Roger could
also have had hockey abilities a level
above anything that we've seen in the
story so far very similar to Shanks and
there's also this giant egg on Roger's
ship that has never been explained so
far in the story seriously what is this
thing an ancient weapon a mythical
creature we just don't know but whatever
this is it is just one more mystery
surrounding the full powers of the
former pirate king and what exactly he
found so funny on love tale and while we
still don't know what Roger found there
we can guess that it was something that
emu wants to have erased from history
the secret ruler of the world has
appeared in just 18 panels in the entire
story and has never said a single word
we don't even know if they're a man or a
woman but every time they do appear we
get world changing events we do know for
a fact that the gorosei take direct
orders from emu they sit on the empty
Throne which we were told no one is
supposed to sit in and were led to
believe that they can order the
destruction of entire Islands but
despite emu's limited panels they are
clearly set up to be one of the main
antagonists of the straw hat pirates
that they will have to face before the
end of the story and so we really have
to ask ourselves what their true Powers
may be do they control an ancient weapon
do they have a super overpowered devil
fruit can their observation hockey span
the entire world like what is the deal
with the giant straw hat in the freezer
and most importantly maybe just how long
has emu been alive because it is very
plausible that emo has lived ever since
the void Century secretly pulling the
strings of the world to keep themselves
alive and in power I know that at least
I can't wait to find out all the answers
to all of emu's mysteries and while emu
is likely one of the final villains the
gurose themselves seem to be the next
World government's opponents that the
strawheads will have to face as well
these five Elders ruled the world
government for emu they have complete
control over the Marines and Cipher pole
and technology developed by the genius
scientist Dr vegapan and they're willing
to have entire Islands destroyed to
protect their deepest Secrets though at
least some of them show remorse over
doing so and while we don't know if
they've been alive for as long as emu
they are certainly not your average
World Noble despite never seeing them
fight it is likely that each of these
men are unafraid of battle many show
scars and one even carries what is
likely a cursed blade as a group they
were not concerned at all about being in
the presence of Shanks without any
guards to protect them plus they also
felt perfectly safe bossing around a
kainu and no one in their right mind
does that if they can't defend
themselves in fact this guy right here
who we now know is called Saint Saturn
had no problem heading straight into
battle and kizaru showed him an uncommon
amount of respect truly we don't know
what the they are capable of but get
ready because some of the answers for
this are likely coming very soon and now
one character that the godosei
definitely wants to eliminate is the
smartest man in the world Dr vegapunk in
the current Arc we learned that vegapunk
has studied the void Century this is a
blank 100 Year time period in history
from 800 years ago and since vegapunk
has been studying it that means he
likely knows all the information about
the ancient Kingdom and its incredible
technology but it also means that the
government is actively trying to kill
him and while the powers from his brain
devil fruit don't have that much use in
actual battle vegapunk's invention
certainly make him one of the most
dangerous characters in the world for
example just two of these new seraphim
that he created are capable of making
even a yonko hesitate and vegapunk has
even successfully recreated actual devil
fruits such an insane ability imagine
more lightning users more dragons or
even more caribou lose weight no please
no more caribous plus it's very likely
we still haven't seen everything that
vegapunk is even capable of if he really
was that close to uncovering the secrets
of the ancient Kingdom Technology then
the world is truly about to change and
one character in particular that
vegapung likely has learned a lot about
is the mysterious Joy boy in chapter 628
we learned that joyboy was a person from
the void Century who was also part and
maybe even King of the legendary ancient
Kingdom and while it is likely that
joyboy was once an actual person it
seems that his name has become more of a
title over time we know this because
when Luffy awakened the sun god Nika
fruit zunisha this giant walking
elephant with a whole island on her back
announced that Joy boy has returns and
so while Luffy was bouncing around with
his insane new powers we don't know
exactly how this made him Joy boy or how
he connects to the person from the void
Century in general not much is known
about the actual powers of that past Joy
boy but we can assume that this person
also possessed the Nika fruit and it was
their role to bring freedom and Joy to
the World this joyber from the past
probably also had access to some
incredible technology and we recently
have learned that the void century was a
time of great technological advancements
that the world today is still trying to
catch up to also joyboy likely could
have used the ancient weapons one of
them could have been used to command
zonesha and if he really had all these
Powers then we really have to wonder how
he and the ancient kingdom ever lost to
the world government 800 years ago
however Ichiro Ora the author of One
Piece has left us a lot of clues that we
can use to learn more about this
mysterious figure the battle during the
void century and how the knowledge that
Joy boy Left Behind will change the one
piece world forever and so everything
that we know about joyboy I explain in
this video that you can watch right here
Shanks for watching